[Music]
hunting from the air is one of the most
complex feats of evolution there is
navigating the world in all three
dimensions while outmaneuvering prey
that have evolved similarly impressive
escape tactics is no small feat
when we think of aerial predators our
mind may go to the fierce birds of prey
like the peregrine falcon who sometimes
dive past their prey and then zoom up
from beneath it to snatch it mid-air
one study showed they have an overall
hunting success rate of 23.1
other aerial predators like hawks single
out individual prey birds from their
flock with a similar success rate of
22.5 percent birds like owls hunt by
pinning their prey to the ground lacking
well-developed aerial hunting techniques
but still only have a success rate of
around 25
other dominant predators on earth rarely
exceed these numbers lions succeed less
than 30 percent of the time
african dogs are perhaps the best
land-based hunters with a success rate
of up to 67 percent when working
together but this number still pales in
comparison to the greatest hunter on
earth and to find this predator you have
to set your sights to something much
much smaller hovering near bodies of
water with beautiful wings and huge
compound eyes
the dragonfly their hunting success rate
pushes a hundred percent
dragonflies belong to one of the oldest
insect orders the odonata which have
been around for close to 320 million
years their presence in the fossil
record is relatively complete and shows
that their morphology has remained
mostly unchanged through time
their size on the other hand has changed
dramatically the ancient dragonflies
were giants compared to the ones that
exist today
what is it about the dragonfly
morphology that led it to be arguably
the most effective predator alive today
and if this particular body plan is so
effective
why did it gradually get so much smaller
over the millennia
why did evolution rob us of a world
where almost one meter long aerial
beasts rule the skies
[Music]
odonata means toothed ones in greek and
these fearsome predators namesake comes
from their prominent chewing mouthparts
with sharp teeth found on the underside
of their head odonates are also
characterized for having a freely
movable head
very short antenna large and highly
developed compound eyes three simple
eyes and two pairs of long wings
the only difference between extinct and
existing dragonflies is their size some
paleozoic species were known to have
wingspans exceeding 70 centimeters
whereas the largest existing species
barely exceed a wingspan of 16
centimeters
males and females can easily be spotted
perching and flying around aquatic
habitats as dragonfly eggs must be laid
in water they generally feed on midges
and other small flying insects that
inhabit the area and hunt and eat them
in mid-flight
and despite being considered relatively
primitive insects dragonflies possess
some of the most unique and spectacular
flight adaptations of any animal
allowing them both to reach fast aerial
speeds and be incredibly agile
one adaptation they possess is something
few other insects do
direct flight muscles
most winged insects have what are known
as indirect flight muscles which attach
to the walls of the thorax making the
thorax deform as they expand and
contract the deformation of the thorax
transmits its resonance to the wings
making them vibrate and initiate the
flapping motion
whilst indirect flight muscles have
their own advantages dragonflies instead
have individual muscles that attach
directly to the base of each of their
four wings
being able to tug on each wing
individually enables them to move and
direct each of their four wings
independently in all three axes meaning
they can control their horizontal
vertical and torsional motion granting
them precision and agility that is
unparalleled by most insects with
indirect flight muscles
thanks to this independent control
dragonflies are one of the few insects
that can propel themselves in all six
directions
up down left right forwards and even
backwards
another remarkable way that dragonfly
flight differs from other insects is
their ability to flap their fore and
hind wings in different phases and can
vary that phase depending on the
maneuvers they wish to perform
one flight technique is known as counter
stroking where they flap their fore and
hind wings 180 degrees out of phase with
each other
this allows them to hover or engage in
very slow forwards flight and can
generate large amounts of lift
for fast forward flight they're able to
switch to phased stroking
where the hind wings beat 90 degrees
ahead in phase of the four wings
while this generates far less lift it
generates a lot more thrust with some
species being capable of reaching well
over 50 kilometers an hour making them
by far the fastest flying insects
dragonflies can also engage in
synchronized stroking which is when the
four wings and hind wings flap together
at the same time this is most useful for
increasing their acceleration and to
prepare for turning or changing
directions quickly it allows them to
generate huge amounts of lift but can't
be sustained for long periods of time so
they generally only use this
configuration when chasing prey in
addition dragonflies are also capable of
flying backwards a flight maneuver which
is not possible for almost any other
animal except a few other small types of
fly and the hummingbird they do this by
tilting their body upwards at 90 degrees
to change the direction of the force
generated by the wings
and finally dragonflies can also choose
to not flap their wings at all allowing
them to free glide take advantage of an
updraft or in the case of some female
dragonflies take a ride with a male who
can hold on to her making him beat his
wings to propel the two of them
being able to switch between such a wide
variety of flight behaviors and aerial
acrobatics is what makes dragonflies
such efficient predators when hunting
flying insects as well as when evading
predators of their own
while not exclusive to the oh donata
dragonfly wings also have a prominent
tarot stigma it's a small pigmented spot
on the leading edge of the wing that is
heavier than the rest of the wing it
acts as a counterweight
from a biomechanic's perspective the
weight of the tariff stigma displaces
the core wise center of mass ahead of
the torsion axis at the level of the
tariff stigma if not for this the outer
leading edge of the dragonfly's wing
would be prone to self-excitatory
flapping and feathering vibrations known
as flutter which would rapidly stall its
flight when gliding at high speed such
aero elastic flutter in resonance are
phenomena that can endanger far larger
structures too such as aircrafts and
even buildings and is responsible for
the 1940 collapse of the tacoma narrows
bridge in the case of dragonflies a
small spot that accounts for less than
0.1 percent of its total body weight
allows them to safely reach a 10 to 25
percent higher flight speed than they
would otherwise lastly a dragonfly's
wings are not perfectly flat plates
their veins form three-dimensional
corrugations that make the wings
performance more efficient from a
structural perspective the patterns
traced by the veins prevent the wing
from warping and deforming as a result
of resonance which enables them to
easily alter their angle of attack and
generate higher amounts of lift but it's
not just their incredible speed
stability and maneuverability that makes
dragonflies the greatest hunters in the
air it's how they see the world that
makes all that agility possible
dragonflies don't just dominate flight
they have incredible vision their
characteristic compound eyes are the
largest in the insect kingdom they are
made of over thirty thousand individual
facets or omitidia which are like mini
telescopes that detect light from the
direction in which they point it
as their eyes wrap around their head
almost entirely their field of vision is
nearly 360 degrees
perfect for surveying their surroundings
for potential targets without having to
reorient themselves on their perch
each ometidia also has four to five
opsins light-sensitive proteins that
absorb different colors of light in the
spectrum and allow dragonflies to
perceive color from orange to
ultraviolet which is useful for hunting
during the day and for detecting and
courting females using visual signals
with thirty thousand omittidia spanning
a full 360 degrees dragonflies do not
have the same visual acuity as a human
or a bird but are much more sensitive to
movement than we are
a common prey target in the distance
will rarely span more than one degree
across their field of vision before they
decide to pursue it which equates to
movement across two to three omittidia
at most meaning their brain is capable
of detecting and processing movement
incredibly quickly so they can
immediately pursue prey or avoid a
threat their eyes are also specialized
based on region the upper or dorsal
region of their eye is most sensitive to
shorter wavelengths of light that is
ultraviolet and blues many dragonflies
fly low above the surface of the water
when searching for prey as this allows
potential targets to contrast as much as
possible with the blue sky on the other
hand the middle and lower or ventral
parts of their eye are sensitive to a
wider range of wavelengths this is
likely because color detection is
important when identifying and pursuing
fellow dragonflies either as potential
mates or rivals which they are more
likely to approach head on or from above
it can also help when identifying prey
that doesn't move such as insects
trapped in spider webs which dragonflies
occasionally loot from unsuspecting
spiders if no flying targets are
available these vision abilities
combined with their flying prowess
create a formidable predator
however it's how these two things are
integrated that make the dragonfly the
most effective predator alive today
it's not just the wings or the eyes that
make the dragonfly so successful but its
brain the dragonfly's brain uses a
highly optimized hunting strategy that
allows it to predict where the prey is
going and to quickly maneuver to
intercept it studying raptors and other
hunting insects has shown that there are
two main strategies used by predators to
chase down their prey tracking and
interception and of the two ways to hunt
interception is the far more difficult
one tracking involves maintaining the
target in the same spot in their field
of vision and accelerating towards them
the chaser approaches and spirals in
towards the prey until its natural
advantage in speed allows them to snag
it the other form of hunting is known as
interception where the chaser flies in
an intercepting path towards where they
predict the prey will be this is more
difficult as the locations and speeds of
the prey and predator must be processed
together to make such a prediction
however if predicted accurately it's
less likely to depend on an absolute
speed advantage which can help the
predator to save power as fast forward
flight and acceleration is energetically
taxing
and even though dragonflies have the
speed and agility to be able to engage
in tracking if they so desired they
primarily use interception as a form of
capture in humans interception is a
learned behavior but in dragonflies it's
hypothesized that such behavior must be
hardwired into their nervous system
linking their visual system and motor
system directly
however an interception model of pursuit
means the prey being hunted is less
likely to remain in the same spot within
the dragonfly's field of view which can
make the prey more difficult to catch
studies have shown that dragonflies
seemingly adjust their head in near
synchrony with their prey fixing their
target in areas of higher visual acuity
for tracking
in fact this synchronization is so
perfect that even the head movements
appear not to be reactionary but based
on predictions
all of this mind and body integration
has given the dragonfly the best hunting
record researchers have ever found in
2012 researchers at harvard found that
dragonflies caught around 95 of the prey
they chased this is impressive for any
animal let alone a flying one
dragonflies will consume any flying prey
roughly the size of their head or
smaller like bees moths flies mosquitoes
or gnats
larger species will even catch an eat
other dragonflies
but if they're the best hunters around
why did evolution push them to hunt
small prey why couldn't they remain 70
centimeter giants dominating the skies
and snatching up bigger prey
[Music]
there are two leading hypotheses for the
miniaturization of dragonflies and
they're not mutually exclusive
the first is that 300 million years ago
there was much more oxygen in the
atmosphere it's thought that this huge
amount of oxygen was able to support
larger insect bodies which rely on
passive and active diffusion through
holes in their cuticle for respiration
as these oxygen levels decreased to
those of the present day
so did the maximum size an insect could
reach
the other hypothesis is that small
flying dinosaurs and birds which began
evolving 150 million years ago may have
out-competed larger dragonflies for the
same ecological niche since there is
less competition if birds hunt larger
organisms and dragonflies hunt smaller
ones smaller dragonflies were more
likely to not go extinct there are very
few insects more successful than the
dragonfly who have remained relatively
unchanged for hundreds of millions of
years
with a killer suite of adaptations to
help it maintain top predator status
it's no wonder engineers and scientists
alike are keen to study and emulate them
dragonflies have been the source of
inspiration for many biomimicry projects
which aim to replicate how they track
targets and perform aerial acrobatics
while to date there are no free-flying
drones of dimensions comparable to a
dragonfly on the market there are
several prototypes of micro-unmanned air
vehicles in the works
so the next time you see a dragonfly
flying around your local pond remember
to take a moment to appreciate this
killer in the sky
and be thankful they are the size that
they are or be glad you're not a fruit
fly as important as dragonfly morphology
is to its enduring success as a species
its behavior and life cycles are equally
crucial not only do dragonflies dominate
the skies but their larvae are deadly
hunters under the water with their crazy
retractable jaws that can shoot out half
the length of their body their world is
even more alien than the dragonflies we
are familiar with and their hunting
strategy even more terrifying
to learn more about the freaky world of
dragonflies and their larvae you should
watch dragons and damsels on
curiositystream it's a 50-minute long
david attenborough documentary that i
had never seen before and dives into the
murky weird world of these creatures and
has amazing close-up footage of their
hunting and flying as well as footage of
mesmerizing experiments done with smoke
to understand the dragonfly's
aerodynamics
curiosity stream is a streaming platform
with thousands of high quality
documentaries like this one and now
curiositystream has partnered with us to
offer an incredible deal by signing up
to curiositystream you now also get a
subscription to nebula nebula is a
streaming platform made by me and
several other educational youtube
content creators it's a place where we
can upload our videos and podcasts
ad-free and a place where we can
experiment with new original content by
signing up to the bundle deal you'll get
access to both curiosity stream and
nebula where you can access originals
like tearzoo's let's play outside series
with episodes about the cheetah's
extraordinary speed or the mantidfly's
crazy mashup of traits from both the
mantis and the wasp all of course set in
the context of a video game battle so by
signing up at curiositystream.com
real science you'll get a subscription
to curiosity stream and a subscription
to nebula for just 14.79 for the entire
year signing up is also the best way to
support this channel and all of your
favorite educational content creators
and if you're looking for something else
to watch right now you can watch our
previous video about hybrid bears or
watch real engineering's latest video
the plane that will change travel
forever which discusses the blended wing
airplane that stands to change how we
fly for good